[Música]
la casa blanca afirma que ya no hay
migrantes en el campamento de la ciudad
texana desde el río al menos 2.000
haitianos fueron deportados otros
migrantes piden asilo en eeuu y miles
regresaron a méxico el presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador aseguró que no
quiere que el país se convierta en un
campamento de migrantes
ciudad de méxico buenos aires y sao
paulo se unieron a las marchas mundiales
de este viernes por el que los reclamos
van para los gobiernos sus contratos
para multiplicar la producción agrícola
y sus inacciones para frenar la
deforestación
'cuba reabrió sus bares y restaurantes
en ocho de sus quince provincias la
estrategia pretende apoyar la economía
del país y relanzar el turismo a partir
de noviembre la campaña de vacunación
masiva planea inmunizar al 90% de la
población para noviembre
bienvenidos a esta emisión dedicada
especialmente al continente americano
soy maría clara caché y comencemos
entonces con eeuu porque el secretario
de seguridad alejandro mayorkas indicó
que ya no quedan migrantes en el
campamento fronterizo con méxico unos
dos mil haitianos fueron deportados más
de 12.000 migrantes están temporalmente
en eeuu y cerca de 8000 regresaron a
méxico donde algunos haitianos ya tm ya
tienen un nuevo campamento el presidente
de este país andrés manuel lópez obrador
afirmó que no quiere que su nación sea
un refugio para los migrantes
alva santana tiene toda la información
el campamento de del río texas se ha
quedado vacío las autoridades
estadounidenses trasladaron a miles de
emigrantes de la zona intentando poner
fin así a la crisis migratoria en la
frontera con méxico
esta mañana ya no hay inmigrantes en el
campamento bajo el puente internacional
del río
sobre el campamento llegó a acumular
cerca de 15.000 personas y dejó imágenes
que dieron la vuelta al mundo de la
policía dando un trato inhumano a los
migrantes algo por lo que el presidente
ballena prometió responsabilidades
por supuesto que asumo la
responsabilidad soy el presidente es
horrible lo que hemos visto ver a la
gente siendo tratada de esa forma
caballos pasando por encima gente
amarrada es indignante les prometo que
esa gente pagará hay una investigación
en curso y habrá consecuencias
ante la política de expulsiones de eeuu
y el trato recibido cientos de
inmigrantes regresaron a méxico donde
ahora piden asilo no obstante el
gobierno de lópez obrador advirtió que
no planea una acogida masiva
no queremos que méxico sea un campamento
de emigrantes queremos que se atiendan
el problema de fondo de la gente no se
vea obligada
a emigrar
porque si no continuamos con lo mismo el
dirigente mexicano también pidió la
intervención de la onu en apoyo a haití
de donde proceden la mayoría de los
migrantes de que vamos a subsistir
la crisis migratoria que enfrenta el
continente también llega a chile cientos
de venezolanos entraron al país austral
por pasos clandestinos en la frontera
con bolivia el gobierno chileno de
sebastián piñera ya había anunciado que
retomará las expulsiones de quienes
ingresen al país de forma irregular
mientras tanto en iquique el cuerpo
policial de carabineros desalojó un
campamento de cerca de un centenar de
migrantes el informe es de que la
maestra
una semana
a pie o colgados de camiones cientos de
migrantes en su mayoría venezolanos
llegaron a la frontera norte de chile-
atravesando un desierto de 3600 metros
de altitud en busca de una vida mejor
y
atraídos por la imagen de una economía
estable progreso y salud que chile ha
consolidado especialmente a través de la
campaña nacional de vacunación contra el
cob y 19 estos migrantes se arriesgan a
llegar por su parte las autoridades
están preocupadas por la manera en que
llega esta nueva ola migratoria personas
ingresan sin ningún tipo de control y
finalmente hacen su cuarentena de las
calles de las plazas en las playas de
nuestra ciudad y eso no debe ser así
chile acoge a casi 500 mil migrantes
venezolanos según la agencia de naciones
unidas para los refugiados empujados por
la devaluación de su moneda la escasez
de medicamentos y víveres en general en
su país de origen pese al anuncio
oficial hecho este miércoles del regreso
de las expulsiones a migrantes en
situación irregular como ocurrió a
principios de año algunos esperan poder
quedarse esto es mejor que estar en mal
estado
venezuela tú uno tiene su casa y todo lo
que tú quieras pero no tiene cómo
alimentar a tus hijos ni ni como
vestirlo ni darle una buena educación
al igual que otras olas migratorias esta
también fue dispersada en las últimas
horas agentes policiales desalojaron las
carpas en plaza brasil en iquique lo que
dejó a varios grupos de migrantes a la
deriva como miles más a lo largo del
continente americano
cambiamos de tema porque se suspendió la
última ronda de negociaciones en mexico
entre el gobierno de venezuela y la
oposición de este país los delegados del
presidente nicolás maduro no aparecieron
para la ronda de este viernes si llegan
los delegados la reunión se podría hacer
el sábado uno de los temas que falta por
discutir son las condiciones para las
futuras elecciones venezolanas y el
levantamiento de las sanciones
internacionales de todo
y américa latina se unió a las protestas
mundiales en contra de la gestión
ambiental de múltiples gobiernos este
viernes se reactivó el movimiento fried
expert filter las protestas que
comenzaron en alemania se extendieron a
buenos aires sao paulo y ciudad de
méjico en argentina se manifiestan en
contra del acuerdo con china para
duplicar la producción porcina en sólo
cuatro años en brasil acusan al
presidente de jair bolsonaro de destruir
la amazonía en mexico la campaña fue en
contra de la petrolera pemex los
pronósticos son bastante negativos hay
distintos escenarios y en todos esos
escenarios los impactos son graves tanto
para los animales los ecosistemas como
para las personas la crítica no es un
asunto del 10 o 20 años la crisis
climática ya llegó méxico es uno de los
países más impactados en latinoamérica
tenemos dos cafés tenemos sequía tenemos
inundaciones tenemos golpes de calor nos
movimos besser nos morimos de calor y el
gobierno sigue financiando la industria
de combustibles fósiles
vamos al norte del continente
la iglesia católica de canadá pidió
disculpas y dijo estar arrepentida por
los siglos de abusos contra los
indígenas es que solo en este año han
encontrado cerca de 1200 restos de niños
y niñas indígenas ellos estudiaban en
internados que manejaba la iglesia
católica y los obligaban a olvidar su
lengua y sus creencias los obispos de
canadá ahora publicaron un comunicado en
el que afirman que están comprometidos
con la reconciliación del país muchas
comunidades religiosas participaron de
este sistema que conlleva la supresión
de los idiomas cultura y espiritualidad
indígena que la falta de respeto a su
historia tradiciones y sabiduría
reconocemos los graves abusos cometidos
por algunos miembros de nuestra
comunidad católica físicos psicológicos
emocionales espirituales culturales y
sexuales expresamos nuestro profundo
remordimiento y pedimos disculpas y
terminamos con una noticia positiva
porque este viernes cuba reabrió sus
bares y restaurantes en casi todas sus
provincias en 8 de 15 para ser más
exacta
estrategia pretende apoyar la economía
del país duramente golpeada por la
pandemia del coi 19 y también esperan
relanzar el turismo a partir de
noviembre mientras la campaña de
vacunación masiva planea inmunizar al
90% de la población para noviembre alba
santana con los detalles
los cubanos ya pueden disfrutar de las
terrazas de los restaurantes de nuevo
por sorpresa el jueves el gobierno
cubano anunció la reapertura en un
intento por apoyar su maltrecha economía
y el turismo que se reactivará en
noviembre hay condiciones para ir dando
paso gradual en una apertura reapertura
de estos servicios presenciales y
también y de alguna manera bueno
restableciendo también socialmente lo
que lo que hemos perdido en todos estos
meses los bares y restaurantes de cuba
que ahora trabajarán con el 50 por
ciento de software o llevaban meses
cerrados tiempo en el que los ciudadanos
de la habana no habían podido disfrutar
de este tipo de servicios presenciales
por eso la noticia fue acogida con
ilusión en medio de la crisis económica
nosotros vemos contenta claro que ha
cerrado nos aliamos compartíamos las
amistades empezamos la universidad de
nuevo eso es algo que no nos apasiona
mucho además de la recesión financiera
joven frente a un fuerte rebrote de
casos desde hace dos meses con una de
las tasas de contagios por 100.000
habitantes más del mundo en septiembre
por eso el país sigue trazando tácticas
para frenar el cobe 19 como la
vacunación para aquellos que superaron
la enfermedad una decisión avalada
científicamente
la isla espera tener el 90 por ciento de
la población inmunizada para noviembre
hasta aquí este informativo continúen
con más en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]